[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and gerbs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show my guest
today I'm so excited to have with us
Todd McFarland he is an Emmy and Grammy
winning director producer and creator of
one of the world's best-selling comic
books spawn he is best known to many
comic book fans for his work as the
artist on The Amazing Spider-Man for
which he co-created Marvel's top villain
Venom Todd is the CEO of Todd McFarland
Productions McFarland toys one of the
US's top action figure manufacturers and
McFarland films he is also a co-founder
of Image Comics which debuted spawn in
1992 selling 1.7 million copies of the
first issue
in 1997 spawn was made into an Emmy
award-winning animated series on HBO and
a live action feature film that grossed
more than 100 million dollars in 2019
Todd made history with spawn number 301
earning the Guinness world record for
longest running Creator owned superhero
comic book series you can find him on
all the social Instagram at Todd
McFarland Twitter Todd underscore
McFarland Facebook like Todd McFarlane
Todd welcome to the show nice to see you
Tim thanks for having me this morning
appreciate it I thought we could start
with a confession on my side ever since
I was a kid and to this day I still have
a poster of the Incredible Hulk number
340 Gray Hulk vs Wolverine that features
your artwork and I am a long time
collector and fan of your work so it's
exciting to have you here and I'm
excited to dig into all sorts of things
and I thought we would begin and this
might be a dead end we'll see where it
goes but
asking about how baseball
informed your approach to Art and Comics
if at all if those two things tie
together for you so here's what I would
say about that and I'll I'll give you a
little bit of back history I would say
it informed me more on the eventual
business side
the the competitiveness on the business
side mm-hmm it's always interesting when
you do certain interviews or with people
I I would just sort of think that
sometimes interviews are like laying on
a psychologist
couch and they're like Todd why are you
like that what drives you right here
here's here's the answer to that
question so we can get that out of the
way I think it was the day I came out of
the womb and it was in my DNA right so
there's not a single day I don't recall
not being taught
so what what is natural for me I guess
for other people because I Now
understand as I get older their
personalities that my personality has
been baked every day of my life and it's
like it's not it's not an effort to do
what I've done in life right so people
go oh my God you're so tenacious and you
go up against people and you're such a
rebel and you you fight for what you
believe in of course there's no other
option in my brain right so it's not I'm
not fighting I just there's no other
option so it's just a natural
progression on where I want to go but I
would argue that whatever that DNA is
got enhanced with two things one I had a
brother that was a year older and one a
year younger and then you get three boys
together what are you talking about
every day was a competition who could
eat the cereal the fastest who could
jump the most steps down who could run
to school the fact what do you talk
about everything is a competition and
then you take that and eventually I was
never going to go to university right I
remember being in class when they
brought in high school they brought the
the recruit and the college and they
they sort of talked and they go well I'm
not going so I'll just put my head down
and continue drawing because I was
always doodling
and then somebody tapped me on the
shoulder I remember and they went
Sun
why is your arm not raised and I'm like
what like what I wasn't even paying
attention sadly and I go well what was
the question they're going well who
wants to go to college and I looked up
and every single person in my class had
their arm up now
that's okay but I looked at the two sort
of druggies that I know because I'm
friends with all of them and I'm looking
at them going
what are you talking about you're not
going to college you got F's like across
the board you might even drop out in
grade 12. like so anyways I gave them my
reason which is I don't enjoy education
and so let's just convert it to broccoli
and let's say I don't like broccoli why
would I then go and pay people money to
eat more broccoli doesn't make much
sense does it so I go I'm not going now
did I go to college of course I did why
because I'm an athlete and and so I
played baseball getting back to your
question and somebody offered me a
scholarship
to go to play baseball so my last three
years I was on a pac-10 baseball
scholarship and at some point now you
have to get sort of simplicit if
somebody's going to give you free
education I'm gonna grab it did I want
it not really but if it's free I'm gonna
grab it and and oddly Tim of the 25 guys
on our team
only two of us graduated with a degree
in four years
and and the other guy was I'm Canadian
another guy was a Canadian I remember
the coach going because Canadians don't
don't want to hustle as much in sports
right because we got a degree like what
he's talking about was free and and the
reason I took it and I got it done for
free because
the dumb athlete was alive and well but
they're not really dumb they just don't
go to class and if you don't go to class
you don't get your marks and if you
don't get your marks then eventually you
don't get your degree here's the funny
thing about that somebody is offering
you a free degree and 23 of my teammates
decided they wouldn't get it in four
years so either they would never get a
degree or gun to my head this is weird
they're going to come back and pay to
finish it I go finish it the buffet was
open the whole time you were there and
you chose not to eat like oh my gosh so
if nothing else given that I'm sort of a
cheapskate I'm going they're going to
give it to me for free I'm not paying
another Penny to come back here I'll
take that degree so I got my degree and
I was Off to the Races now now between
the baseball which is competitive and
that my brothers then all of a sudden it
three weeks before I graduate I end up
getting my first job in comic books and
all of that sort of made me a freelancer
and I had to begin taking care of myself
and it's like okay it's just another
game another game of competition
first job in comic books you've posted I
want to say photographs of 350 or so
rejection letters when did you first
start sending those out and did you get
any particularly helpful feedback that
allowed you to modify things so that you
were able to get that first job
so let's go through it real quick
did I get over 300 rejections yes is
that tenacious is that determination or
is that delusion what point do you say
I'm going to be an opera singer and
people keep giving you no's and you go
man look how determined is at what point
do you say maybe I just can't sing opera
right right so there's a fine line
people give me way too much credit for
those 300 I think a normal sane person
with sort of less enthusiasm we'll leave
it at that word than me would have
probably at 200 rejections found another
option to make money but the reason I
was able to assimilate that many
rejections was because I was going to
college so I was sending off samples
almost continuously
while I was in in school so it's like I
didn't have a job I was going to school
so I didn't care I had four years to
basically try and get a job and then it
probably at the end of those four years
I was going to look at that pile and say
maybe I need to find something else my
degree is I thought is in graphic
designing and I thought I was going to
be the guy who's going to do Michelin
tire ads right I go that's okay it's an
admirable job but you know it's a
graphic designer that was sort of where
I thought the reality of it was going to
be so but three weeks before I graduate
I get my first job and how did I get it
by sending literally 700 samples over
the course of those four years and just
on one level I think I just wore them
out because I sent it to every editor at
every company and so they they used to
have let's say at Marvel because my
first job was at Marvel they have like
one submission editor no no no no no no
the people who give you the work are the
editors and they have 16 editors so I
would send it to all 16 editors
ultimately I went around as a mission
guy I just want what you're not you're
not you got to give it to the editors
anyways might as well send it directly
to the editors so I would keep sending
it to the editors over and over and over
to every company every editor and I
think Tim in hindsight I think that they
probably had a board meeting or whatever
one of those Monday morning meetings and
they just said something like and I'm
making this up but said over the love of
God that Todd kid
that that that punk that keeps sending
us we keep getting like a box of mail
from this guy every two weeks with
somebody in this room give him a couple
Pages just so we don't have to open up
his mail every two weeks I think I just
I think I just wore him out and and I
got the job literally three weeks before
I graduated so I never even had to use
my degree now what informed me in those
it was all constructive criticism let me
tell you because people say oh Todd you
got the last lap no no
everything they put in those letters was
constructive criticism because the
people who just thought that I was you
know not very good through my my
portfolio my samples in the garbage so
everybody who took the time to write
back actually gave a little bit of sort
of insight and so what I would do that
didn't know it was actually going to
keep me fueled is that I would take that
insight and then redo another batch and
send it to everybody again so I you know
where I was making 20 mistakes
eventually got down to 18 and then 16
and then 15 and I think probably when I
was at six mistakes I think they finally
said hey he's getting better he's not
perfect but and he seems to be
enthusiastic so somebody give them give
them a chance see what he can do
so for people who don't have any
familiarity with comic books penciling
anything along these lines what were
some of the things you were getting
feedback on and getting better at and I
suppose this list leads into the
question like what
what does it look like as a comic book
artist to get better what are you
getting better at maybe that sounds like
a silly question but I'll give it a shot
there's two things that I think make a
good artist in the comic book industry
one is just you know pure drawing skills
right so there are
hundreds if not thousands of people who
can draw circles around me
so that if you can just draw pretty
pictures you can go a long way the
second piece is
storytelling
and if you can do great storytelling and
be average jar you're still going to
have a pretty good career
because people then will be
entertained
by everything you do so I'll use an
example and I hope because I'm friends
with him I hope he doesn't take it Frank
Miller is a great great Storyteller he's
the one that wrote The Dark Knight for
Batman he's the one that you know
created 300 that ended up getting turned
into a movie in Sin City and all these
things he rejuvenated Dead characters
like Daredevil
I wouldn't say and I think Frank would
agree that he's not the best
anatomically correct artist and his
drawings don't get every muscle right
what he does is he tells stories
better than anybody else in our industry
period so he could do it with Stickman
and you would still be engaged because
of his writing the way he does it and
and what's happening in it so Frank has
been able to take that storytelling
which to me as I've gotten older is way
more important than whether you've got
flashy lines I came in as a kid who
wanted to do flashy lines because it
would people go oh my God look at all
the detail he's doing but then I found
out that really what they wanted was
less Flash and more clarity on the pages
right you should be able to give a comic
book to a non-comic book writer you know
go go next door to your neighbor give it
to your mom and at the end they should
be able to say hmm you know not my cup
of tea I don't collect comic books but
that was kind of interesting because
they understood what they were supposed
to be reading in the sequence they were
supposed to be reading it and if you
don't do that you're no good in our
industry one more thing if you can't
keep a deadline
then you're for sure not good at
anything as a matter of fact people who
can keep a deadline in an industry that
is driven by monthly deadlines
can have long careers and not be very
good at drawing because you have to get
product out every 30 days so go ahead if
you want to be the kid that's flashy and
do a bunch of lines and take twice as
long but they're never going to give you
a regular gig because you have to get
books out on time period out
I'm embarrassed that I don't know this
but you can still learn a productive
life Tim don't worry about it yeah I'm
working on it working on the productive
side but what are the deliverables on a
monthly basis are you are you shipping
out a few pages at a time are are they
waiting until you have the entire book
done so to speak what what do the actual
deadlines and deliverables look like for
a full-time comic book artist so it is
shifted as you can imagine with
technology right so the way that it used
to work and I'll age myself because I
got into the business sort of
pre-internet
I'd have to do my pages
take them to the either phone FedEx and
they were called Federal Express at that
point
and so I would have to phone Federal
Express when I use FedEx my wife go oh
you're so hip calling them FedEx and
then eventually they caught on
um
but so your phone FedEx they'd either
come and pick it up or sometimes you
would miss the call on their deadline
they were the drivers were passed I was
living in a remote area up in Canada and
on an island in Canada and so I if I
missed a driver I I would literally
which is why I hired an assistant to to
help sort of package stuff up he would
drive to the airport which was about an
hour and 15 away while I was finishing
up pages
which I go oh I've got another hour and
then we drive to the airport
do you know how many times I've ran down
the tarmac because it was a little sort
of prop plane that flew to Vancouver
British Columbia and they were I think
it was always looking over his shoulder
going to be here in about two minutes
and I'd be running down the tarmac and
and I basically throw my package to him
and he'd get it done today all of that's
taken away because now you can you can
scan your pages and hit a literally a
download boom it's gone it doesn't solve
anything Tim all's it means is you just
get to push your luck with deadlines
later and later so let's give you an
example currently happening the biggest
comic book that's going to come out this
year in our industry is a book called
Batman spawn right so that goes to print
because I just talked to the people at
DC Comics yesterday it goes to print on
Monday right you and I are talking on
Friday
I still have to write it's a 48-page
book I've only written eight pages I've
got to finish writing the 40 pages
there's 10 pages that haven't been
colored I literally talked to the person
who does the word balloons after I give
them the script uh to say hey sorry dude
we got to both work pretty hard over the
weekend they're gonna probably get the
last pages at midnight on Sunday they're
going to look at it make sure nobody no
pages are upside down or backwards and
then they're going to hit send and it's
going to go to the printer and the
printer is waiting because when when
you've got a big print run because this
can like I said it's going to be the
biggest of this year
you can't swap out books and say ah
we'll just swap out another book and you
just substitute not of that magnitude
they've got lots of printer presses
waiting for this one book and that we've
got to deliver so how does it work by
our chinny chin chin like a lot of other
things in the world you just get it done
so well so let me back up for a second
because I think I heard you correctly
now you have delivered so many deadlines
even if you've chased down the plane on
the tarmac you've I've missed the plane
a couple times you've missed the plan a
couple times so this is a huge book
biggest in the industry of this year did
I hear you quickly that you said you
have eight pages done out of 48 I guess
I'm just wondering if you're writing
quite yeah writing wise okay wow I'll
tell you what that means that means
before I talk to you this morning I
talked to my what they called a letterer
the guy who actually converts your
script into the word below yeah yeah I
talked to my letter and go dude
we're going all night tonight I'm just
every three pages I'm gonna send to you
so it's gonna be I do three I send it to
him he works on it by the time he's done
with those three I'd feed him another
three and we're just gonna see how it
works and we'll get it done Tim we'll
get it done I'm right like you said
earlier I believe a couple years ago I
set a record I mean spawn is the longest
running Creator on book we're up to
issue 335. that's over 30 years of doing
books and now I do a monthly book every
week you just it you just get it done
it's like going to the gym every every
every workout isn't awesome but did you
get your workout in yeah sure
wow by the hair of your chinny chin
nobody knows on the other side nobody
knows everybody's going to look at that
book and go that's true nobody knows
look how professionally done it was
so
so let's then come back to a word you
used which is important and that is the
longest running Creator owned superhero
comic book series The Creator owned
piece
when and how did you decide to start
Image Comics because I remember as a kid
I wanted to be a penciler for about 10
years I was I was really tracking all of
this and I was an illustrator in high
school and then part of college I
actually had the I was the graphics
editor at a magazine where Jim Lee had
been the previous graphics editor so I
had the same desk that he'd used it
means I had a DC Comics for those I
don't know yeah and he had these
sketches in the desk that he'd done
after getting hammered in college and I
thought these are just treasures at the
time so
this is this is a lot of fun for me to
explore and I remember image being a
very big deal so for people who have no
context can you explain
sort of why and when
image was founded because uh I think
that's a big piece of this story look
and I assume that the majority of people
listening don't collect comic books and
whatever so we'll keep it simple
everybody knows Marvel and DC everybody
right if you ask the next natural
question huh who's number three
that has been image comic books for 30
years we are celebrating our 30th
Anniversary so it was the spawn
character because it came out that first
year
and we've been number three for 30
consecutive years as a matter of fact
those first couple months we came out we
actually passed DC comic books we were
number two for a few months so when
people sort of get past you know the
Marvel in DC and even in the industry of
Hollywood and or people that are looking
for ancillary products right which you
have to because in case people don't
know
Marvel's owned by Disney
Marvel's owned by Disney they don't
share that too much and uh DC comic
books is for a long long time has been
owned by Time Warner now you know Warner
Brothers Discovery at T you know but
let's call it Warner Brothers so one's
owned by Disney ones owned by Warner
Brothers okay so your Sony your
Universal your Paramount Studios
your your Netflix your Apple your your
Paramount plus what are you talking
about where you're getting product not
getting it from Marvel why they're not
sharing and you're not getting it from
DC because they're not sharing so you
literally have to go and redact all
those books and and and you're left with
everybody else and that puts our books
in really good position now let's go
back because that doesn't answer your
question how did we get to image comic
books for me personally when I was
trying to break into comic books like I
said in all those years uh leading up to
Breaking again those I was reading
everything I could get my hands on about
our industry
and what I found
was I was coming across a common theme
and the common theme was
that everybody
no matter how big your standing had been
in our industry
eventually got pushed out against their
will
and in some cases got the short end of
creative and financial sticks and these
are artists these are artist writers
whatever these stories had been written
over and over and over again and so I
remember you know one in particular
reading about there's a gentleman his
name was Jack Kirby and his nickname was
Jack the king Kirby Right to put in
perspective to people who were Layman
listening that they called him the king
for a reason because he was
and he got the short end of the stick
Jack Kirby's a guy who helped create the
Fantastic Four and the X-Men and even
created the the costume for Spider-Man
and the Hulk and Iron Man and on and on
that's who Jack Kirby was right he
helped create it with Stan Lee
so
I remember reading those articles and
this is long before I break into the
industry and I want man if they can do
that to Jack King Kirby they can do it
to anyone and so when I got my first job
in comic books when you know three weeks
before I graduated I went in with my
eyes wide open
and so I knew what the game was and I go
okay their job is to exploit me as much
as possible
can I
do the same
in Reverse at the same time the win is
they're getting something of value out
of you you're getting something the
value out of them and the value that I
was getting out of them was twofold one
I I had all these dozens of characters
in my portfolio including spawn and I
never ever had one second of Temptation
to ever pull any of those out and offer
them to to Marvel or DC when I was
working with them did I create new
characters when I got the plots from the
writers of course I did I was a
professional I helped co-create and I'm
the visual creator of Venom right so
Venom's my guy why because I you know we
came up with a story and that was what
it was okay fine but I never said oh man
I'm having a good career at Marvel let
me reach into my portfolio and offer
them my characters never
why because in the back of my mind those
stories had been haunting me that were
there and at some point Tim
I was selling more comic books than any
human being Marvel was employing period
to the point that I had set a record on
one of the books I helped take over
artistically Amazing Spider-Man it was
sitting at like number 22 in the sales
chart they came and they went hey Todd
if you want to draw out cool because I
had just finished a run on the
Incredible Hulk that you had mentioned
and they said whatever you want to do
because it's sort of in a dumper
Spider-Man's in the dumper in short
order
at some point Amazing Spider-Man became
number one or two every single month in
total sale
to the point then that they're like oh
and it's really what catapulted my
career and and just so you know all the
things that I was doing artistically to
help move it from number 22 to number
one
I was getting pushback from the
corporate entity up above and the
executives up above and the
editor-in-chief up above that you can't
do what you're doing Todd you're messing
with the icon that's not how we do it
let me tell you ladies and gentlemen as
an old man now the single greatest
danger you are going to meet in your
life is status quo it is the thing that
they are going to fight and battle you
against more than any other thing in the
world and what's staggering about what I
just said which is a truism
is that there's only 200 percenters in
the world that I can give you one we're
all gonna die hate to break it to you
it's just a matter of time the second is
everything is going to eventually change
otherwise we'd be living in caves right
now change is part of the human
condition and yet every day you run into
systems that are crushingly holding on
to status quo or holding on to yesterday
and and for those of us that are wired
to think about tomorrow we become the
rebels we become the outcasts we become
the people who are rocking the boat who
are just Todd why don't you just you
relax get along all the things that
they're going to tell you and what I'm
saying that happened to me has happened
to millions of people throughout history
that wanted to do something different
not better let me be very clear no not
better different so when I was doing my
different Spider-Man I wasn't doing it
because I thought I was better I wasn't
doing it because I thought what they
were doing was worse which is how they
took it I was doing it because I'm a
young kid with a career and I need to
figure out how to stand out in a sea of
people that are doing the exact same job
as me and there's only one way I've got
to be a little bit different so I
started doing some funky fun little
stuff on Spider-Man and guess what the
fans liked it and more importantly it
was enjoyable for me to draw because
drawing is a lonely occupation like a
novelist where you sit in a room for 12
hours a day with you and your thoughts
that's your day and if you can't
entertain yourself it's a long day so I
was coming up with crazy little silly
things I was putting in the book they
were having a heart attack I was getting
called on the carpet has the sale bills
are going up they've I I finally quit
Spider-Man they go no no because you're
selling so many books we'll give you an
a new Spider-Man book they were going to
do a fourth Spider-Man book anyway so
they could have one every week of the
month so they gave it to me I've never
written before I'm going you're going to
give it to me I've never written before
but I I got it right which is why I quit
I go I want to write and and that's
because I don't want to draw other
people's stories I want to tell my story
and they said yeah yeah and that book
set a record it's in the Guinness book
of world's record for the for the most
sales by a single Creator I also own
that record on the other side with spawn
I own the corporate and non-corporate
record for a single issue by a single
person done now I'm not saying that
bragging I'm just saying that has a fact
so that now that guy who's set in
records when he comes into the office in
New York from Canada a little Canadian
hick
you would think that they would say
thank you not [ __ ] you right and instead
they're calling me on the carpet going
Todd you've got to stop doing this and
this and this all the things that got me
and their books were there and I
remember having these bizarre
conversations with the editors going
dudes you don't have to like me
personally you don't have to like my
drawing style you don't have to like
anything I do you hired me for one job
sell comic books you guys are in the
Commerce business don't you realize
you're a money making machine you want
to sell books I do that better than
anybody that you employ why are we
continuing to have these conversations
and they wore me out Tim they wore me
out
was there a particular moment when you
knew it seems like you had basically in
your back pocket the plan to eventually
go out on your own because you had all
these characters you developed so what
was what was the day or the conversation
where you're just like [ __ ] this now is
the time I'm splitting on remember with
Clarity comic books have this thing in
the corner called the comics coat and
the comics code was created because in
the late 50s there was the whole were
them scared that comic books were
degrading the Youth of of America and
they had the Senate hearings and it
actually in a weird way ended up leading
to the sort of the Advent of Marvel
Comics because they were Marvel was a
company called timely Comics but then
they went uh oh we don't want to get
caught up in this whole Senate hearing
let's sort of sort of whitewash if you
will our our presentation and they
change their name to Marvel and their
first book out Fantastic Four and then
after that here comes Spider-Man Iron
Man Hulk and all the other things that
we all know right but so you can argue
that thanks to some Looney Tune in the
senate in the late 50s Marvel exists
right maybe minus him there is no Marvel
so we actually we shouldn't be given all
the credit to Stan Lee we should be
giving it to McCarthy and the Dr Wortham
who was the one who wrote the book The
seduction of the innocent right so look
it up anyways because of that Comics
code every now and then they would get
you to fix a panel Todd you can't do
that why because the comics go okay now
I used to ask him could somebody
actually send me the compass code so
instead of having to guess what's in the
comics code and then you guys tell me I
got to redraw something because I have
headlines and I don't like to redraw and
redo anything and so it's like burning
your your pasta then you go oh man I
gotta cook it and boil the water again
it just you get aggravated the second
time around so at some point they kept
doing that and then the day came and
then it was the proverbial straw
that broke the camel's back because I'd
been doing it for years and they sat
there and it was this issue and it was
the sideways issue my last issue at
Marvel it was a sideways issue of the
Spider-Man book the one I had I was
writing myself except for we were doing
a crossover with some of the the mutant
X-Men in this case X Factor characters
the ones that were sort of Deadpool and
cable came from those characters and
there was a bad guy and his name was a
juggernaut and the Juggernaut was like
you couldn't beat the Juggernaut right
big giant dude and he had armor and you
couldn't do it so my thing was well he's
got isolates he's got to look out those
isolates and so the way that I was gonna
get to him was I had one of the mutants
take their sword and put it in the eye
and he and jam it in the eye because
then it would be like oh my gosh right
you'd catch him off guard and then if
you team tackle him you're gonna win the
day
so I drew that I still have that page
today Tim because it's the page that
broke the camel's back right I have the
I have the unedited version even better
I I I don't even have the edited version
I have the unedited version and so they
phoned me up and they said Todd you got
to redraw it and I want what what do you
redraw what you can't stab somebody in
the eye
with a knife and I go what are you
talking about like the comics called I
go well of course you can because
just not long ago there was this great
cover Not only was it in the it was on
the cover of Daredevil Frank Miller and
he's got bullseye on the cover and he's
stabbing
Elektra a character on the cover
and so I go of course you can stab
people and they go well
yes you can stab people but you can't
you can't have a rear exit wound and I
want what are you talking about did you
look at that cover the guy's killing the
lectures going in the front is coming
out the back no no no no no no no no no
no no no you can stab them and it can
come out of your exit room but you can't
tear the cloth so if you look at the
drawing you're going to see that it's
like you don't really see the sword
coming out it's like a teepee it's like
a teepee the back of her costume it's
like it's cheapy but it hasn't cut so I
go so I just want to be clear you can
gut somebody
and you can have it come out the other
side after you gut them you just can't
rip the cloth and that won't offend the
mothers and the children yes wow okay
um so there's no rear exit wound I'm
just stabbing them in the eye yeah but
you know what people are sensitive to
eyes because if everybody gets something
in their eye we all know how much pain
that is and teeth because if you go to
the dentist and he drills you wrong and
I'm having this absurd conversation with
five or six of my editors and I'm just
going what oh so I just want to be clear
can I stab him in the chest yes in the
knee yes in the elbow yes in the eye no
in the cheek yes in the neck yes in the
mouth no
wow
wow so somehow it just I was in Bizarro
land and so at that moment I stopped the
conversation because you never want to
have a conversation with anybody where
two plus two equals giraffe right never
talk to somebody who comes up with that
equation so I said guys here's here's
what's going to happen I'm gonna send
you the page
I'll do a little quick drawing over if
you want you guys fix it any way you see
fit
by the way I'm handing in my resignation
I am done I am exhausted I also was a
few days
away from becoming a father for the
first time and I just want you know what
it's time to catch my breath I don't
know what being a dad's about these guys
have worn me out and all I do is sell
books for them and I just called Uncle
and that was it that was the day I
walked away now did I have a plan B of
course I didn't Tim of course I did the
plan B was I had spawn as a character
and I just want I guess I'll just have
to self-publish right not ideal but okay
here we go the upside of it was that I
was talking to a couple other people let
me all say before me quitting I also was
going around trying to create a union I
was like the normal Ray I would go come
on man power to the people right if we
stop drawing put pencils down they got
nothing to print we we show them our
power
it was frustrating for me when I tried
it for a few months that that the most
scared people that will say yeah let's
join together
are those that don't have a job
it was weird to me I would I'd be
talking to dozens of people that I knew
that wanted to be in a business that
were in a business but weren't getting
steady work that needed a better life
and I go come on let's just go let's
just create like a an enclave of of
people and deal with the whole is better
than the parts and they would say no
Todd I can't because what if they
blackball me and I'm like blackball you
what do you talk about you're not
getting any work from them right now
yeah but what if they blackball me I'll
go so dude here's what I'll do for you
right now you have no job no car no
girlfriend no house no money
if you joined this Enclave I will
promise I will make all of those equal
to you right you've got nothing to lose
other than to go up
come on man I'm I'm selling more books
than anybody else I'm making more money
than anybody else in our industry and
I'm willing to throw it away
you should be ten times more Fearless
than me it was actually oddly the
opposite so during that time I had been
talking to my friends and peers they
were also in the industry a gentleman by
the name of Rob life out and another one
named Eric Larson and both of them had
that same entrepreneurial I'd like to
just call it rebellious trait in them
and we were always talking and I
remember in one conversation Rob was
saying yeah I'm gonna maybe go you know
I'm working he's still working for
Marvel so is Eric and it's like yeah I'm
gonna go do my own book and then Eric
was on the call going yeah I'm gonna go
do my own book and I had just quit and
at some point during the conversation
the topic came up go well if you're
going to do your own book on your own
Rob and you're going to do your own book
on your own Eric and I'm planning on it
why don't we do all of them together in
the same place it's never been done
what's happened is
people have left Marvel and DC one at a
time or they pushed them out the door
think of it like a sports team so you
lose a free agent you'll go get another
player so you lose enough but what if
10 of your players on a championship
team quit the same year that would be
detrimental to that to that competition
of that team so the conversation was why
don't we just join forces so all of a
sudden very quickly it was three Rob
who super energetic came up with the
name image comic books and the reason
why you came up with the name so he
tells me is that there was a commercial
that was on TV and it was uh Andre
Agassi I think and it was a it was a
camera commercial and he says image is
everything
so that was the punchline of the
commercial so he was like let's do image
right if image is everything let's do
image right so that was it image column
you don't overthink people think that we
come up with all this stuff and we know
what we're doing no Venom in and of
itself was a happy accident we can go
back to that in a minute if you want to
but so the three of us get together and
then and then Rob says Todd
I've got a buddy Jim Valentino he does
some independent comic books uh is it
okay if he comes and it's like what are
you talking about like there this is a
group the more the merrier so we've got
four and then we find somebody to help
us publish
and
we say that's it we're flying to New
York and we're going to break the news
to Marvel that we're quitting four of us
Rob Eric Todd Jim
Jim Valentino
we fly to New York
and I land the day before we have a
meeting with the top people
Terry Stewart who was the publishing
head at that point and
later at that meeting I'll get to was
the editor-in-chief who had just
happened to be walking down the hall
right so
I've got a meeting with Terry Stewart
the top dog and to basically say we're
quitting here's our reasons why and
if it was me I would close this barn
door because you might have some more
people quitting next week or the week
after the week after so we land the day
before and I gotta blow some time so I
happened to walk around I heard there's
an auction
somebody selling some artwork I go to
the auction and Jim Lee the person you
know you talked about the beginning yes
now the head of DC combo Jim Lee is at
the auction and he's like hey Tom what
are you doing here I'm like oh and I
told him
and then I start giving the sales pitch
Tim let me tell you one thing
when I have my passion involved
I'm a good salesman I'm a good salesman
and so I start pounding on Jim Lee and
Jim Lee at this point just so you know
he's doing the X-Men and it is the
number one selling book he's doing the
number one selling book yeah huge
the only time I ever got beat was Jim
Lee right that guy he was he was my
competition so like I was Magic Johnson
he was Larry Bird okay and so we just we
had our rival but we liked each other
and we got along and so I tell them what
we're doing and he starts thinking about
it and then to my surprise says
I think I can go with that now this is a
Monumental moment from my perspective
and here's why ladies and gentlemen
Todd the rebel leaving
was going to be easy for for Marvel to
basically discount because they were
going to go ah that kid's always sort of
rocking the boat and he's always a bit
of a pistol you know what that's fine
Rob liefeld had the same attitude so
it's like oh we were the Bad Boys ah so
the bad boys left good riddance Jim Lee
was The Golden Child he was the chef's
kiss he was the guy he was perfect if
they could clone employees an artist Jim
Lee was the mold and so when Jim said he
would go that was a Thunderclap in my
head to go oh my God if the choir boy
can go
then that means all bets are off and
they are going to have to sit up and pay
attention because not only are you
losing the Bad Boys you are losing the
model citizens and so Jim then says oh
by the way I got a pal wolf protacio you
know
is it okay if I phone him and because
he's looking for work I think he'll join
too
shoot he was doing another X-Men book
I'm going what we're gonna get two X-Men
the X-Men books are the number one
selling book at that point bring them on
till we got six and I'm walking now back
to my hotel with the biggest grin on my
face because I go they don't even know
what's about to come and as I'm walking
into my hotel I see another sort of peer
a guy by the name of Mark Silvestri now
Mark Sylvester to me at that time
was the best artist like just in terms
of skill Mark Silvestri I don't believe
the thing that my son is saying yeah
that's my dad I'm take care of here
right yeah yeah no problem Mark
Sylvester is there it's about 11 o'clock
at night and I go hey Mark what are you
doing he goes oh I'm going to bed you
got you got you got five minutes for me
right and so I sit down and like
Mussolini from the balcony I give him
the speech right and I give it to him
and he's like oh my God he goes Todd
that sounds good Andrew Lee's on board
yeah he just signed on
let me think about it I go Mark here's
the gig we've got a meeting at eight
o'clock tomorrow morning
I need to know if you're in or Not by
eight o'clock in the morning you go so
I've gotta I've got to go to bed I've
got to think about it whether I'm gonna
change my entire career and I've got
nine hours of which eight of them I'm
gonna sleep
yeah that's it now I don't know what he
did or how well he slept that night but
in the morning at 7 30 the phone rings
and he goes hey Todd Mark I'm in
seven we went to New York I flew to New
York with Rob with four of us with four
of us and by the time we walk into that
office we've got seven oh by the way
Mark Sylvester was doing the Wolverine
Comic Book we had literally the Dream
Team to put in perspective for people
listening again that don't know
there's probably a every year about that
year was probably about six seven
thousand comic books come out but from
all companies right because again
Spider-Man comes out once a month so
it's 12 and then you've got three
Spider-Man books that's 36 and then
ironman's another 12 and 12 and you add
it all up literally thousands of comic
books come out the people who
like gathered together to create image
we had
accomplished 44 of the top 50 sales that
year just to put in perspective who we
were 44 of the top 50 sales of 6 000 we
were literally the comic book equivalent
of the Dream Team the basketball team
that was happening in basketball at that
time so I knew this was going to
reverberate somewhere and again the
stock went down at Marvel the next day
take a look at it because CNN reported
on it
and we went into the meeting
and essentially it went like this and
here would be a fun interview is to get
Terry Stewart's perspective of it
because not only has he literally lied
about it he will tell you otherwise but
not as he lied about it but then 30
years later I met up with him and my
wife went and talked to him and he still
is spewing the LIE right and I get it
he's corporate what's he gonna do he
doesn't want to say that it was on his
watch that all these people left but
here's his lie
and it is because I've got I got
witnesses because there's more than one
of us in that room is he's saying we
came in and we asked for the copyrights
of our characters what are you talking
about none of us is that crazy we
understood the Dynamics of the business
we would like yeah give me Spider-Man
and give him the X-Men what are you
talking about that's his that's he's
saying he had to let us go because that
was our demand no no
the way that it went down was simply
like this we are leaving
there is nothing you can give us that's
going to keep us
and oh by the way here's some of our
reasons if it was us you may want to do
something about those reasons because
next week you may have another seven
quitting I don't understand why you want
to keep having people quitting but you
know what
do what you got to do it's your company
whatever now during that conversation
the editor-in-chief had
coincidentally happen to be up on the on
the upper floors don't know why and just
came in and whatever he was a good man
Tom DeFalco
the one that used to tell me can't do
that Todd you can't do that Todd on
Spider-Man so anyway at the end of this
conversation because Rob life out who
was in there and my wife was there and
Jim Lee was there Rob laughed because he
had to go pick up his girlfriend so that
was classic Rob like oh you just
finished this world-changing
conversation I go get my wife and gotta
grab a burger so and this is why I like
Rob so much because he's just he he's
he's by the cuff and it's what makes him
special to me anyways we get in the
elevator at the end of this conversation
and I will never forget the words has
the elevator doors are closing just like
in a movie the doors are closing and you
can see the editor-in-chief looking at
us and he says
hey
if it doesn't work you're welcome back
and the door's shut
and I remember turning to Jim Lee now
just to give a little background on Jim
Lee Jim Lee went to college to become a
doctor I think his dad's a doctor this
is a smart intelligent human being
and for me my dad who you just heard was
in the printing business for 40 50 years
the one thing that I knew it's printing
and if not I knew lots of people who did
so the doors closed and I looked at Jim
and I go oh my God they think we're dumb
oh and I'm not that we're smart Tim not
that we're smart Tim but you know what
printing comic books is
ink on paper that's it ladies and
gentlemen Inc on paper done maybe
there's a couple details beyond that but
that's it the every time you pick up a
pen and you write on a piece of paper
it's sort of kind of like doing comic
books it's just if you keep going and
draw it in the shape of Spider-Man or
the Hulk you got a comic book it's not
rocket science and so I was like oh my
God they don't think we can print oh my
God so that was it and from there the
collective whole of the seven of us left
here's sort of this silly funny part of
the rest of that day
historically what was happening Tim is
that if you quit Marvel you only had one
choice you want literally across the
street to DC Comics or if you quit DC
Comics you quit and you walked across
the street to Marvel that's all you did
you literally ping-ponged your whole
career back and forth back and forth
whenever you got mad you just went to
the other date that was across the
street so we went across the street to
DC comic books I'd done about a year
year and a half there Rob life out had
done a year there but Jim Lee and I walk
in there Jim Lee has never stepped foot
in DC comic books and he's The Golden
Child at Marvel
and they just go there's only one reason
he's in the office
somebody got mad and we're getting The
Golden Child and we're getting taught
we'll take the bad boy too because he's
like that's these are the number one and
number two selling guys in the industry
we hit the motherload the mother oh my
God and quickly they assemble 15 16
people in this room and they pour the
coffee and they get us the refreshments
and they just go oh my goodness we are
sitting here and we sit down and then
they hear the Fateful words I go hey
guys just so you know we're not here to
work for you just a couple things we
just quit Marvel their eyes light up but
we are not here to work for you either
and they you could just see the lead
balloon and they were like pardon and
it's like no no we're not here to work
for you so you came here with Jim Lee
and walked into our offices and are now
dangling and teasing us and saying it's
for nothing that's exactly what we're
saying
wow wow why would you guys do that and I
go wow
because you know we got some other plans
and then they start giving their sales
pitch well here's why you should work
for us don't do that DC is your place to
be DC DC DC and they go and by the way
we just did a new contract that's for
the betterment of the creative community
and then I asked them the question for
me that was like the dagger for me was I
go hey you know no that was super cool
that was super super
you wrote up that new contract for the
creative Community could I just
just like one one question here just
before we got going did you ask one
[ __ ] creator
to have any input in that
contract that is to better the creative
community did you ask one single Creator
and let me tell you Tim when you get
pregnant pauses in rooms it's all you
need to know you get your answer at the
pregnant pause of course they didn't of
course they didn't and that was the
reason this is why we're quoting Marvel
this is why we're quitting DC because of
your disregard
for your community
and Jim and I are examples and we've
climbed the top of the ladder just like
Jack King Kirby and all those hundreds
before him this is just a repeat of
history and it's time and we thought
that that was it and that was when the
collective whole not me the collective
whole of the seven of us started Image
Comics
so the DC visit
I'm trying to think of the names
involved was there anyone who is
quitting DC or did you just go in there
to put them on alert and say no we put
them on alert and gave him the same sort
of speech we gave Marvel if you think
that the dissatisfaction of the seven of
us is unique to the seven of us you guys
are blind I see so it was a change your
ways or become a fatality right every
conversation is the exact same and if we
prove that there's any success on the
outside of the only two bubbles that
exist in most Freelancers
sort of brains which is Marvel DC or you
get another job
and I mean another job in another
industry so if we if we move on and we
create a third possibility why why do
that now to their credit let me say Tim
to their credit
they did
start changing they did start bettering
pay and you know even starting to give
medical which was never a part of the
equation and giving bonuses and being a
little more fair-minded on royalties
because they knew that what we were
saying at some point that reality sunk
in that we could start losing almost all
of our top talent if not a big portion
of our talent period and this isn't good
for business right so so even those that
were jealous or in our creative
community and or thought that we were
crazies or whatever they still whether
they know it or not prospered by us
leaving because all their contracts got
upgraded while they were still throwing
darts at us our own Community as you can
imagine
saying you guys go take your big Egos
and go do your thing
okay so I just came back from a bathroom
break you mentioned before we started
recording you had a camel bladder and
that you would talk until I had to take
a bathroom break which was true
so how is how is a camel bladder a
competitive advantage
so what so why so you you don't go to
the bathroom I mean I went to a signing
not long ago and I got there at seven
and I signed from seven in the morning
to midnight and I didn't move from the
desk where I was signing from now again
other human beings had to eat and go to
the bathroom so I go you better have two
teams then you're gonna have to rotate
them
let me just sort of quickly get out of
the way first how you cannot go to the
bathroom for 17 hours it's really sort
of easy stuff if you don't put anything
into your top hole nothing comes out of
any of the bottom holes right just it's
just basic so I don't eat and I don't
drink
that's a whole nother conversation but
like they're going what what how do you
do that that's another conversation but
if you don't put anything nothing in
nothing out simple easy and I know this
to be scientifically true because I've
used it to my advantage now because I
have a camel bladder two things have
happened in my career that I think have
been advantageous one everybody when I
go to the conventions would have to go
and take a lunch break why because
they're hungry
they're hungry like my wife would tell
you I have never uttered those words I'm
hungry I eat because science says I need
to my body needs fuel so I put it in not
because I'm hungry because I have to
it's an essential ingredient food
so I do it but I cannot last you if
you've got to go away so people would
take off at conventions and go away for
lunch or bathroom breaks or whatever
guess who didn't
me and here's why that matters because
there's people in line and if you've got
at the time of our popularity when they
used to open it up you'd have at times
I'm telling you literally thousands of
people in line waiting for your
autograph first off in good conscience I
can't have somebody waiting in line for
two hours three hours and then look at
them and say cut I'm going for an hour
and a half lunch break and the kids
going what I've already been in line for
three hours like I can't do it I can't
look at somebody in the eye I won't do
it so I said no I'll just figure out how
to not do this thing that most humans do
so and here's where the upside is is
that when all my peers have gone to
lunch then people are waiting in line
and then they're just sitting there
going well that guy's still signing
what's his name Todd Tom Tim whatever
what's he do Spiderman well I like comic
books I know Spider-Man and guess what
happens Tim they'd get in your line they
don't care really at that point about
you they just go he's signing the line's
moving I'll get in his line and then
they come up you've got 20 seconds
you've become as gracious as you can to
them and maybe you peel off and you've
got a new couple fans and all of a
sudden it's like you know I only collect
X-Men but you know that Todd was a
gentleman and he was very nice and he
smiled at me he was very kind you know
what maybe I'll go buy one of his
Spider-Man books or you know in the
future respond books and so that's it
good right I'll always be nice to
anybody no matter who they are number
two on the business end and this one is
sadly even easier and it's just pathetic
at times
I live in Phoenix Arizona and Phoenix
Arizona can be 110 degrees let me tell
you I'm like a cockroach I don't care
what the weather is I'll survive don't
worry about me I'm good but here's what
I know about other people they have
comfort zones and so whenever I was in
some big legal dispute or contract
dispute I would say especially the
people in L.A I go you fly them to me
you fly them to me now this is just the
Art of War so my desk is facing a big
giant glass window right and I know when
the sun comes down that window now when
usually when I'm in my room I bring down
the drapes and I put up the AC and I'm
comfortable but when the enemy is coming
I.E the people I've got to negotiate
with come right I make sure that the
blinds are up and that I turn the air
conditioning so that it's actually
stuffy in that room because why I can
endure it I've done it plenty of times
and then they always come dressed in a
three-piece suit wrong move guys wrong
move and then they come in and they come
into the room and I close the door and I
know it's going to get stuffy and then I
put a giant pitcher of water in front of
them and then I uttered the words
guys this has been going on far far too
long here's the deal
we're not leaving this room until we
settle every single outstanding point
and during those conversations
they either pour their own water
on a constant basis because they've got
their three-piece wool suit on I've got
my t-shirt and my and I'm in my my Nike
shorts
and I can just see them getting hotter
and hotter and hotter and they keep
having to get more and more water and at
some point nature calls and then we get
down to the last one and they go I go
I'm not moving on on point ten I'm not
moving it's a deal break if I don't get
it this whole deal and you know how many
times I've had people in my room go fine
this is how it works it goes like this
time fine you can have point 10 are
redone yes are we done yes where's your
bathroom the very next thing is where's
your mask because I think in my mind
that they literally came in on the 10th
point because they couldn't hold it
anymore and if they could have held it
they could have argued longer with me
and perhaps I might have conceded or we
could have compromised on that point but
their bladder cost them too bad how sad
you find your advantages wherever you
can get them
oh McFarland the Barbarian what a Savage
nice work so
let's come back to Venom you mentioned
that Venom came together I think as an
accident maybe a happy accident yeah I
mean this is an iconic character how did
it come together
so we'll go back early in my Marvel
career like I said
early in the podcast if you can keep
deadlines that's a giant value in that
in that industry so I was showing them
that I could keep deadlines so I knew
then that that was going to be getting
me continuous work so once you get
continuous work the next upgrade
is can you draw characters that people
have heard of right so because the first
job I got at Marvel was on a book and it
was like an obscure book it was called
Steve engelhardt's coyote and and it
wasn't even coyote I was doing a backup
in the coyote I was doing an obscure
backup in an obscure book it literally
was starting in the mail room
but eventually
I I got a steady job over at DC because
I canceled coyote and I got a I got a
monthly book over DC unfortunately Tim
and this is where sometimes one person's
break is another person's tragedy an
artist on another book
who was a fit human being with super
awesome artists I followed him
was a health freak drank some
unpasteurized milk went into a seizure
and had an allergic reaction and died oh
my God and so I get a phone call and
they go hey Todd my artist just passed
away can you come on and help us for a
couple months and I at that point they
had canceled coyote I literally took me
years to get in I was employed for four
months and then they canceled coyote and
I'm like man so I sent my samples back
to all the people that were gracious
enough to give me constructive criticism
except for a thing changed on the resume
Tim I was now able to say
I am Todd McFarland the professional
from Marvel comic books the drawing was
exactly the same it only been four
months it was just as horrible as it was
four months earlier except for instead
of being an amateur I got to go now into
the smaller pile which is the
professionals looking for work pile so I
get the job I go yeah I've got some work
the guy who was supposed to take over
that book because I was only supposed to
fill in for two months decided to bail
so after the first issue
they said do you want to take over the
book it was a book called Infinity
Incorporated and I stayed on the book
for two three years so when I went over
the Marvel they went okay you can keep a
deadline check the question is you got
to stop doing and here's a bizarre thing
that was happening at Marvel at that
point you got to stop doing what they
called your Big Dice drawing style and
the only reason it was called that
because on one page in Infinity
Incorporated I drew this page layout and
it was these big giant Dice and then I
did panels inside drawings inside the
Big Dice and somebody I guess an
editorial saw that page and so it was
like oh he's the big giant dice guy
and the reason I was doing giant Dice
and doing all these crazy flamboyant
layouts in an Infinity Incorporated
because Tim my drawing was mediocre
I knew that like at some point you got
to be realistic about your skills I was
I was mediocre and I had two choices I
could either put mediocre drawings and
boring
layout or I could be flamboyant and
baffle them with my BS and get them to
look at all this sort of window window
trimming and not so to pay attention
that maybe I'm drawing my eyes crooked
right and it worked and it worked so
people were like oh my gosh and so by
time I left Infinity I think I had risen
to the point that I was like voted the
fifth most popular penciler at that
point so I'm like wow so I go over to
Marvel and then they say which was weird
because Marvel was always the house of
ideas and at this point they were in
they had flopped with DC and they were
they were boring and they said you can
come but you can't do the giant dice
style and I go so what do you want me to
do and I go we just want you to do like
a grid now let me just tell you anybody
listen that means you take a piece of
paper and you divide it into six equal
panels and you go it is the most boring
easiest thing to do so essentially they
took a guy like me who I thought was an
artistic Sprinter and they said could
you put lead boots on
shoot this is going to be easy right I
don't know why you want to do it but it
was frustrating because there was no
artistic freedom to do it so I did it
they gave me the first job back at
Marvel and they go hey problem you
usually have 30 days to do a book right
once a month
but we're behind the eight bar we can
give you this job but you only got 10
days I gave it to him an eight was it my
best job of course it wasn't
but was it done to Nate yeah did it get
me brownie points right on the spot they
were amazed I gave it to him in eight
days boom within weeks they're offering
me the Incredible Hulk now once you get
the Incredible Hulk this is the next
step in climbing the ladder all of a
sudden look I've been in the business
probably
two three four years at that point and
when I get the Incredible Hulk finally I
hear the words from my mom and dad oh my
God you finally made it and the reason
was because they'd heard of the Hulk
right so up to then everything I was
doing was like I don't know if he's ever
gonna make it I was still working at
Marvel in DC it just wasn't for books
but if you can go to the neighbors you
know uh Halloween party and say my son
draws the Hulk they've heard of the word
Hulk too so all of a sudden it's like oh
my gosh your son he must be good so you
it's it's important to have characters
that know because it it helps the
relatives in your circle so to think
that you're a bigger shot than you are
even though it's the exact same amount
of work and the same pay on top of it so
okay so you get to the next step and now
you're going ha now you're just fighting
for the next step up and I'll quickly
sort of get you to this and I know I'm
long-winded and all your questions I
wish I was better I'm into it
run with it so I do the Hulk I'm doing
penciling and then I go I'm gonna do
inking because at this point I got fast
enough that I could do two books there
wasn't too many people that could do two
books I was doing two books so they give
me a second book the same editor who
gave me the Incredible Hulk gives me
another book it's called GI Joe Real
American Hero right now the thing that's
sort of ironic about that is I was
living up in Canada right and it never
really sort of I was going wow they only
knew that this Canadian and I'm Canadian
up here in Canada drawing the real
American Heroes this might this might be
a bit of a problem but nobody's going to
tell there was no internet
so I did it the first issue of GI Joe
and I was doing the Hulk and I got a
phone call and I was going back and
forth with this writer and it was we
were bashing heads
every single page of that and finally
after the first issue my editor phones
up and says Todd I've got to let you go
unlike one issue I'm one issue in the GI
Joe I'm making my marks on the Hulk
because now I'm St I'm now in the top
three of some of the voting artistically
and I go what you're gonna fire me but
let me just tell you it was a relief
because it was such
a pain for that one month and that my
view of comic books in The Writer's view
of comic books were so diametrically
opposed where did you guys Clash on that
what kind of decisions he probably sees
it a little bit differently but I'll
just show you given my point of view I
assume the people that were reading the
comic books had eyes and brains
he assumed from my perspective they
didn't because he said it his words not
mine assume the reader is an Aboriginal
Bushman and he just came out of the
tundra in
Australia and he's never seen a comic
book your storytelling must be that
clear which basically meant you can't
have somebody walk into a house and then
cut to them like inside the house or
even closing the door on the inside you
have to grab the door open the door walk
in the room because and I just want I
guess I see the world differently I
assume silly me that the people reading
the comic books watch [ __ ] TV go to
movies read books they understand how
stories are told and as a matter of fact
on a movie when you cut scenes they
don't even have a caption in 99.9 of the
time so people just know that it's
different people in a different setting
it must be a scene cut you don't have to
do it but anyways he had his way of
seeing the world I had my way of seeing
the world fine no big deal got it so he
fires me off it and I remember I was
sitting in my Department up in Vancouver
and I leaned back and I looked at the
clock and it was like 1206 and I was
like a little bit bummed I'm like man
I've never been never been fired right
so it's like oh man at 12 14. bring I am
telling you no lie seven minutes I was
unemployed for seven minutes bring
Todd yeah hey this is Dick Giordano over
at DC now remember I'd left DC to go
back over to Marvel
you remember when you left you said the
only reason you would come back is to
draw Batman
yeah well we've got this book and it's
like first there was Batman The Dark
Knight then there was Batman year One
and they had another project called
Batman year two we've got a book called
Batman year two and the artist it's a
four-part story and the artist quit
after the first one can you finish the
last three what like what you're saying
I my choice right now is either stay on
which I didn't have an option but I stay
on GI Joe that I just got fired from
that was basically like putting daggers
in my eyes or or do Batman and that was
the only character I'd come back for
so I jump on Batman year two now it gets
a little crazier by that point because
because at this point I was only being
the pencil artist and in comic books
they bring in another person who is the
anchor some people call him the Tracer
it's not true good anchors add a lot to
pages
I thought I had my drawing Styles what I
would call sort of this new wave 90s
style and I was constantly getting
anchors that were like these 1960s old
school brush guys I I was drawing in a
way that I thought you should be using a
pen because there's a different
technique with it and they kept putting
brush guys on me and and it was so
transforming like you like they
literally would bury the artwork from if
you saw what I was drawing you saw the
printed page it was like to me night and
day so I do part two of Batman year two
then I do part three and then they send
me the samples and I and I finally again
another one of those moments in my life
with Clarity that I look at it and I see
this flash page and the splash page has
a Commissioner Gordon and he's holding
the gun and to me it looks hairy right I
go it's metallic why is it looking hairy
and it's because the the inker was doing
these lines that worked for him I guess
and then I looked at like another panel
and it was the hallway and when you're
doing like a downshot of a hallway the
line to get closer it's basically
perspective I want more people but it's
just the illusion of depth and I'd done
all these drawings or these lines to
give that illusion and they were
horizontal and then I looked at the
panel and he had done the exact same
thing it was brilliant except for he did
them vertically right and so I was like
and it was these moments and so it
wasn't that one was better than the
other
right they both work it was again I just
sort of try to get as simple as possible
the reason and I don't know if anybody
sort of could understand this concept
but the reason I made them go up and
down
vertically was because silly me I
[ __ ] wanted them to go up and down
vertically because if I had wanted them
to go horizontally which was another
option I would have drawn them I can
draw horizontal lines equally as well as
vertical lines the reason they were
vertical because I must have meant
horizontal that's why I did like what
are you talking about just
copy the lines and do your thing with
the lines that are there and and so I I
phoned the editor and I go hey Denny
I don't mean to do this to you because
you already lost one artist and I don't
mean to do power and plays because I
don't like doing that I don't want to be
that guy but here's the gig if I can't
ink the last chapter of this book and
let me be completely honest I've never
Inked before so I'm a complete noob
I can't do this I can't do this I can't
have people literally going in the
opposite direction of my artwork I can't
do it so
he kind of was in a tough spot he was
like oh okay fine Todd can you get it
done by the deadline yeah sure so
I did my first thinking so thanks to all
those anchors for turning me into an
anchor and from there on out I was my
own anchor I started inking the Hulk if
you look at it I went back to my editor
on the Hulk and go well they let me ink
the Batman and so he's like oh okay I
guess you can ink The Hulk and so and
then and now I'm gonna eventually get to
your question about Venom so it was a
long-winded way sorry that's okay let me
pause you for just a just a quick sec so
for people who have no contacts on your
art I mean very fine details and when
you're talking about the older School
inking lots of thick black you simplify
you simplify it right so when you went
from penciling to I need to Ink this or
I'm out what what were the biggest
differences between penciling and inking
as someone who's never Inked I'm just
I'd be curious to know what you learned
or felt or if it just mapped over really
easily what was it like to do your first
thinking here's the first shock that
sometimes my enthusiasm gets the better
of me and there's nobody that hates Todd
more than Todd at times because it's
like what are you doing Todd right so
then I learned the magic I'm now gonna
do two jobs if you pencil a book you get
30 days if you ink A Book Like I pencil
it they give me 30 days then they hand
the pages to you Tim you ink it you get
30 days if I want to pencil and ink they
don't give me 30 plus 30. yeah there's
two of us it's 30 plus there I get 30
you get 30. they're going you can do two
jobs Todd but you still only got 30 days
essentially you're doing twice the work
and you have to do it twice as fast
because the book still comes out and so
lesson learned if you're gonna pick up
more work you might want to ask how much
extra time do you have and when the
answer is zero you might want to rethink
your ass because eventually I got to the
point of going I'm gonna write my own
stories too and that extra time also is
zero but that comes a little bit later
in the career so the first shock is I've
now got to go faster
what it taught me personally because now
I'm doing two books and I'm inking right
I like so I'm a bit of a unicorn at this
point because very few people can even
pencil too but was I had to create for
myself
efficiencies and this goes into business
now right and and even though we're
doing art this is just efficiencies so I
do the efficiency and I go I don't have
time to do a lot of what they call under
drawing I gotta literally draw with ink
I don't have time to do the job twice I
can't pencil and then ink my own work I
have to do it all in one Fell Swoop
which is horrifying to people who've
never Inked themselves because every
person I've shown among some amazing
peers among some amazing peers when they
see what my process is they go I can't
even make out what's on your page and I
go that's okay I'll just kind of finish
it with the ink and I go no no no no no
no you can't go with the ink I'm like
why because it's permanent I'm like what
if you make a mistake
uh there's a thing called whiteout you
just white it out and they're going yeah
but what if you make of another mistake
I just use whiteout let me ask you a
question in Reverse what happens if you
draw a pencil and you make a mistake oh
I just use an eraser Well why can you
use an eraser and I can't use white out
it's the same thing yeah but it's ink
and it it literally was just mental wall
for people and these are people that I
would sit next to at a convention that
would do 20 sketches with a pencil and
never erase one line and I used to turn
to them go why couldn't you've done that
with ink and their answer was always the
same what if I made a mistake you didn't
I've been watching you for four hours
you haven't made one mistake why is it
if I change the tool that somehow you're
gonna make a mistake but you know what
you do you I'll do my thing and so I had
to just pull back the drawing and figure
it out in one's kind of in one step so I
could keep the deadline that was that
was my learning experience now question
number two
did I hit the ground running of course I
didn't of course I didn't
but if you look at my inking at the
beginning it's very very crude and and
even on Spider-Man which is the book the
Catapult and if you look at the
thickness of the webs on his costume you
will see a noticeable difference I think
from issue 300 when I started Incan
Spider-Man and if you look at like about
issue
320 for sure by the time I get on the
new Spider-Man book that I'm drawing for
sure there's a dramatic difference
visually so I was constantly learning
that trade it was it was Todd the
professional who'd been penciling for
five six years and Todd the Newbie
anchor you know I wasn't going to be a
five or six year vet Incan I was a new
anchor so I had to learn that trade and
catch up those five or six years that
the other half of my brain had already
sort of tackled with penciling So
eventually now that's going to get me to
Venom so yeah to Venom yeah yeah so then
I I finished the Batman project
and now I'm back down to only one book
so I can do two book and so again I I'm
looking for another book and all the
editors at Marvel said hey yeah yeah
yeah you know come and talk to me but
whatever you do don't go into
the Spider-Man office because it's a
shambles now
you may or may not have gathered
that Todd doesn't seem to color inside
the lines a lot of the times and so yeah
you don't tell me don't go into that
office right because unless you want
Todd to go into the office yeah what are
you guys doing so I went to the office
and it was he the editor Jim sauerkraut
at that time good man
was losing and turning over artists the
books were in a bit of a sales decline
like I said when I picked up the book it
was like at number 21 22 and I said hey
I can do another book and we had a chat
and
I said I I want to Ink the book and then
I'm like wow you know maybe in a couple
months and I go on mink into Hulk right
come on go talk to Bob the editor on
that book and he's like well you know
just give me a couple months you how
about it starting at 300 you can ink the
book and I'm like yeah okay
we'll do it but the other piece of it
was oh yeah is this one other sort of
slight problem Spider-Man's got a black
costume
and this is this costume that was
created and for this book called Secret
Wars which is the black costume with the
white spider on it and I go that's not
Spider-Man to me maybe I'm just old
school Spider-Man's that guy in the blue
and the red with the webs on it
Spider-Man
so can we just get rid of that black
costume and uh get back to Spider-Man
and then this is sort of the happy
accident he said wow
you know the editor-in-chief really
likes the black costume and I don't
think he's going to go for that
so he's not going to want to get rid of
it he had something to do with Secret
Wars and you know they kind of digging
it and I went oh man I just I don't want
to draw Spider-Man a black costume it's
like doing Batman and polka dots doesn't
make any sense to me so what if what if
I come back to you with some designs we
just rip the costume off him we put it
on somebody I create another character
give it to the writers we'll just figure
it out and then we still have the black
costume and then we can get the red and
blue back on Peter Parker and it's a
win-win-win he was like okay that might
work so I go away I do the drawing the
costume was alive so I go oh it must be
an alien so I created this big giant
hulking alien and gave him the big eyes
and the slobbering teeth and to me it
was a gorilla it's like an alien gorilla
the claws and everything else and that
was a design for Venom we didn't have a
name at that point but just go here
here's the new bad guy here it is go
and I looked at and went oh that's kind
of cool
we'll give it to the writer and so they
gave it to the writer they cleared it
through upper management they said yeah
yeah that seems like a reasonable thing
the writer comes back to me and says uh
Todd the guy is Eddie Brock and I went
whoa whoa whoa whoa
The Writer's name was David whoa David
uh Eddie Brock Eddie Brock's a human did
you see my design like I like
information I could have used earlier I
would have designed it differently if I
knew it was a human that I was putting
the black costume on but I I sort of
like the design I thought it was cool
and it was Giant and I thought that it
would be more formidable for Spider-Man
to go up against something that was way
bigger than him than another human
humanoid form and this is sort of the
geeky stuff that us creators go through
yeah so I said but man if Bruce Banner
little [ __ ] can turn into the Hulk then
by gosh why can't Eddie Brock somehow be
buried in this costume somewhere right
so we never sort of wavered from it
Venom comes out has a big play and issue
300 Amazing Spider-Man 300 sales go
crazy we knew we had something on our
hand because every time Venom kept
coming back the the male again there was
no internet but the mail kept getting
bigger and people were like oh my gosh
oh my gosh oh my gosh
and so now fast forward with hindsight
and Venom is
a worldwide brand
you know made a billion dollars for Sony
in a movie so again there's the happy
accident and if you look at issue 300 if
you want to go buy it it comes with a
couple of things one it's an anniversary
book sales have gone way up on it one
it's an anniversary book issue 300
Amazing Spider-Man goodbye
some of the very first early work of me
on Spider-Man and my first inking job on
Spider-Man but more importantly
it's the origin of venom right and so
for people they spend hundreds of
dollars if you get these books greatest
thousands of dollars you can get the
origin of venom I don't consider that
book if you were to ask me is that the
origin of venom no it's the issue how do
we get that damn black costume off Peter
Parker so I can draw the classic red and
blue costume because that's Spider-Man
to me right Venom I didn't care at that
moment about Venom it was I get rid of
it the last page of that issue Peter
Parker gets rid of the black costume
because he has a fight with venom venom
goes on his way and he pulls a box out
from underneath the bed and he pulls out
the classic uniform the red and blue the
one that to me is Spider-Man and the
last page which I still have today
because it was like finally I'm drawing
Spider-Man because I I started on issue
298 nope black costume 299 nope black
costume and every page but one of issue
300 but that last page it was and I even
says it even says I think a captioner
says and a new beginning and to me I go
finally I get to respite this was for me
finally now
somehow Venom was the byproduct of that
right now here's what should happen Tim
an employee should come into the office
they should say no he's wearing the
black costume we want to give you the
job on Amazing Spider-Man one of the
granddaddy books
of the company and most sane employees
will go eat yes sir yes ma'am when is a
book due
I don't know Todd is Todd and yeah yeah
right and so I just was like no I need
the red and blue costume
but because of some of that
arrogance ego immaturity whatever you
want to call it your byproduct is you've
got a character called Venom that now
creates Carnage in this whole salute
right so if I was that guy that that
employee
all of that maybe never materializes
that's the true possibility of that and
then I just take all of that member
Marvels at their boring storytelling I
start pushing the boundaries of
Storytelling to make it more I thought
Dynamic I thought everything we do in
comic books is just a Broadway play you
must everything should be big and you
should be talking and Performing for the
lady with bad hearing that's in the last
row at the at the theater so that's what
comic books are it's bravado and so I
was doing all this fancy storytelling
and my editors were going Todd you can't
you can't you can't you can't and I'm
like yeah yeah okay but I just kept
doing it eventually I was asking them
and I go why can't we and I go well the
editor-in-chief gym shooter
he doesn't like that
I found that to be impossible to believe
impossible to believe Jim shooter wants
vanilla when he can have Tutti Frutti or
a banana split hard to believe so we
went and had a meeting one time my
editor Bob Harris who ended up being the
top dog at DC I think he still is maybe
and
we went into this meeting with Jim
shooter the editor-in-chief where every
every editor was literally shaking in
the boots from Jim shooter he was like
this authoritarian sort of figure And he
as we're walking in the meeting all Bob
says don't ask him about storytelling
thought because he just wanted to say hi
to me because I was this new guy on the
Hulk in my career was starting to Bud
and he just wanted to say hi to me it
was just a casual conversation we have a
nice pleasant conversation and then it's
like he goes okay I've got to get to my
next meeting and I'll go yeah yeah and
as we get up because I wanted Bob to be
moving I went oh hey Jim just had one
one one one quick question
can I change storytelling like let me
just ask you am I allowed to have
characters burst out of the panels
because that was what they I was doing
with Spider-Man they're going you can't
you can't
and he was like looked at me
quizzitively and went
yeah sure why
okay but can I can I do this other thing
yeah yeah sure
and I went so so it's okay for me to to
because I go I think I heard somebody it
wasn't Bob my editor standing in front
of you this must have been somebody else
told me that somehow that you said you
can't have panels overlapping and you
can't have characters punching out and I
walk them through a couple things and he
was horrified
and he was like what what are you saying
I'm going yeah yeah that's just what
they're telling all the artists
and he was like no and he got angry at
that moment he goes no I never said that
he goes here's what I said you cannot
and I knew this was the answer Tim I
knew this was the answer he said you
can't do bad overlapping panels and bad
drawings of people jumping out and then
he explained to me the difference
between a bad version and a good version
right and I knew what the bad and good
version was basically don't have a guy
jumping out of a panel and you're
covering up half the drawing of the next
panel right as long as you're doing it
in some negative space you're okay just
as long as the storytelling is clear I
don't care how you designed it Todd I
knew it ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding and shoot from that
meeting on you take a look at my layouts
in Spider-Man it started getting crazier
and crazier now Jim shooter gets pushed
out very quickly I keep doing my Todd
thing on Spider-Man I keep and here's
what I did on Spider-Man that literally
catapults it my career it was a simple
move they were doing Spider-Man emphasis
on man I flipped it to Spider-Man
emphasis on the word spider so when he
put the costume on I thought he was an
insect and I didn't care about Anatomy I
didn't care whether it mattered I just
cared about the Dynamics of this
character looking like a bug man and
crawling in a way and then as part of
that I added more webbing on his costume
and then I had to come up with a new way
of doing his webs that have been done
this way for 30 years I go it doesn't
work if you want to shoot it towards
camera or if you want to create a false
sense of volume which is the only thing
we have as artists you must give the
illusion of 3D given that you're drawn
on a 2d piece of paper so again all
these silly things that would bore
people
but I was doing it and oh by the way it
[ __ ] looks cool it doesn't bore me no
this is key these are important
decisions and here's the moment I was
talking about earlier
the moment you start missing with
anybody's icon
status quo comes into the equation
and I'm now messing it I probably could
have done what I did with a lower tier
character
but not Spider-Man Spider-Man at this
point again at the Republic company is
on their checks every check's got a
little Spidey on it he's on there he's
on their quarterly reports he's on their
internal memos and I'm messing with that
look right and so they came and they
were sitting there and they took it as I
was doing something
I thought they were doing it wrong and I
was right no no no no no no here is the
reality of it I've said it plenty of
times I thought that the look that had
been presented the classic look that was
there the one that everybody if you
close your eyes you have in your mind if
you're a certain age was literally the
Norman Rockwell version of Spider-Man it
was perfect and the best I could hope
for as a young budding artist is to do a
bad version of that and go man that's
almost as cool as Norman Rockwell's
painting let me tell you if you're going
to be a painter never paint like Norman
Rockwell the best you're gonna get is
man he's almost as good as Norman that's
the best you can hope for you will never
be better than Norman right he's already
conquered that Hill go find another Hill
and make it your own you can take pieces
of Norman Rockwell but you can't be that
exact same look so I was putting all
these different looks together and
coming up with some crazy stuff and just
making the spider part of it the eyes
got bigger more webs I reinvented the
web being I made the blue a little bit
darker I forgot about anatomy and I put
them in these cool funky poses that the
readers just went crazy for and every
single time I walked into the offices
what so I didn't go there that often
they would call me on the carpet and
they would say no no
stop it stop it Tom denies it I'm like
Tom there are moments of clarity in my
life this is one of them that Tom Tom
DeFalco was the editor-in-chief he's an
Italian guy and he was giving me hack
again wiggling his finger going you
gotta stop doing the big eyes and this
and this and then he got so mad I
remember his face getting a little red
and he goes and and and that webbing
those damn spaghetti webbing you gotta
stop it now all now from my perspective
ladies and gentlemen if you're in my
head it's like a Charlie Brown sort of
cartoon all I heard was blah blah blah
blah blah spaghetti webbing and I went
oh my gosh I've got a name for them now
so I was like so happy in that moment
because Tom gave me an official name for
him they've been known ever since has
the spaghetti weapon thank you Tom the
Falco I think he was cussing me out and
giving me heck at that point I I wasn't
paying attention though because I was
like oh super cool I've got I've got a
name for it
he then says in that same meeting Todd
you just got to control this stuff and
my answer was and anybody
is under the age of 30-ish listening I'm
going to give you a bit of a golden rule
anybody ask you to do something
especially somebody in Authority always
say yes even if you're not going to do
it it's just way easier you get out of
the room faster don't no confrontation
just nod your head yes in agreement and
go do it whatever the hell you want and
I knew that the editors would only
Circle back like every 90 days
and look at the books and do their
evaluation
and I walked out of that room not only
did I not make the webbing smaller I'll
show you the issue they got twice as
long right because they just look cool I
got to tell you Tim they look cool I've
seen the books I've seen them I've seen
them I have them at home they wiggle
their finger at you and they go no and
next time I go to New York they'll go no
Todd but here's what was happening and
here was their conundrum
sales were going up
sales were going up and at one point
again I had that conversation
that it's like Tom
what do you care how I draw what do you
care all you should care about is that I
am selling you comic books and I you
gave me the task of moving Spider-Man
Amazing Spider-Man from 21 up the ranks
and it's at number two right now Jim Lee
and X-Men were beating us and and I was
at one meeting it was odd there was this
stranger in the room I never met him
before didn't know who he was and he
just sat there silent the whole time he
had this big fat book I didn't know who
he was and then at the finally at the
end of an hour conversation when I said
that I go I'm selling more damn books
than almost anybody you employ right
here right now this dude I found out
later was an accountant he opened up his
big giant accounting book Tom came
behind him the accountant didn't utter a
word he just pointed at something on his
data sheet and he shook his head yes
yeah
what he just said yes sales are going up
and you could just see that it was like
what did we do right it's working but we
disagree with it because the status quo
is getting let me tell your audience
here's the Bizarro thing and now that
years have passed everything they told
me not to do on Spider-Man that I was
rebellious against and I just stuck to
my guns and I did it and the sales are
do you know that if you're a young
person right now and you go to Marvel
and you draw Spider-Man do you know what
style you have to draw Spider-Man in
Todd McFarland
so the guy who was told not to create it
I've now bizarrely as I was going no I'm
not going to draw that status quo I'm
going to do something funky
my style is now the new status quo and I
don't think anybody should draw on Todd
McFarland's style because the next
person they should be encouraging to do
their thing because it might be five
times better than what I ever came up
with I don't understand corporations of
just coming up with an idea and glomming
onto it so hard yes I'm talking to you
IBM and then this little dudes in the
garage come up with this little computer
and they call it an apple and somehow
they beat you eventually because you
become dinosaurs and this is the thing
there is nobody in the world that's ever
made change and everybody like them
especially the people who were had the
power and The Prestige and the money
ahead of them nobody if you go to any
Corporation and you say I've got this
new idea you will never hear the words
from the people that are the industry
leaders that sounds super cool let us
get out of your way so you can just do
that on your own unfettered are you out
of your mind they will take out Bazookas
and blades and put down the [ __ ] the
strips and the throwing darts and they
will do everything in their powers to
discourage you because they are industry
leaders but eventually they become Their
Own Worst Enemy
Todd we are at almost two hours now I've
realized that we've barely scratched the
surface we've established a lot of the
background of course the personality the
rule breaking see camel bladder and we
have not even touched upon your personal
relationship with Stanley which is of
great interest to me we have not talked
about the toy empire we have not talked
about how any of that started TV film
music
spawn I mean there's a long list of
things that I would love to cover with
you would you be open to doing a round
two I think people would certainly be
interested in listening to One
could I convince you to come back for a
round two Tim you'll find that like I'm
not shy at opening my mouth and talking
to the point I'm always going am I
boring people because I actually know
all these stories because I lived them
but yeah I think there are some
interesting Forks in the road that may
be not interesting for my career but
just sort of the human condition of what
happens when you get to certain walls
yeah I've been talking about what I had
to do
in one industry but now because of that
success what you just mentioned I and it
was able to break into multiple
Industries and found
some of the same
sort of repetition and how you navigate
the Sharks when you're a guppy right so
uh yeah I'll come back I appreciate you
giving hopefully we haven't bored people
these two because they'll go why would I
want to listen to another two so I'll
it's your show I'll let you decide
whether that works
ultimately I mean what's called Selfish
self-interested if I keep it interesting
for me just like you in those 10 12 hour
days you got to keep your artwork
interesting to you because otherwise and
even maybe still it can be really lonely
so for me I just try to scratch my own
itch and asking questions about the
things I'm interested in so I'm very
interested I'm sure we'll have plenty of
people along for the ride and people can
find you on all the social handles that
I mentioned of course are there any
other places you'd like to point them so
they can find you on Instagram at Todd
McFarlane Twitter Todd underscore
McFarland you can find it these are
hipsters right I'm the old guy like if
they type in your name yeah they'll find
you people if you're interested you can
you can find it what I'll try and
Endeavor the next time is to answer more
than three questions because I think
that's all you got in I need a temper
and get like Todd he just asked you how
old you are you don't have to talk about
the entire sort of evolution of humanity
to get to that answer but but I think
that a little bit of backstory to get to
the of reasoning why when you make that
call at that moment
matters oh yeah it's critical yeah so
we've now painted hopefully some of the
personalities so now we can just maybe
be a little more
varied into questions and we can pepper
and jump around a bunch of Industries
and I can tell you some silly stories
about those ones too yeah we'll get into
the trenches and we can hear more of
your our divorce stories right and today
I almost killed Eddie Vedder we'll talk
about that there we go that'll be the
Cliffhanger and everybody listening as
usual we will put show notes and links
to everything in the
show notes at tim.blog podcast and uh
until next time don't be afraid of
rocking the boat and consider your
upside downside just like you were
talking about those those artists
earlier
an image it's uh human nature what a
thing and Todd thank you for making the
time today so to be continued and we'll
figure out a time for round two thank
you Tim